[Music]
one of the most well-received shows that
I have done since the Super Bowl was
with mr. Warren sharp and mr. Warren
sharp is back
hello mr. Rockley happily the second
thing that I did after experience in
that was I watched the show action on
Showtime and there was this guy and I
was like yo this man takes no [ __ ] from
anybody and he tells it like it is and
we embrace that here on the left coast
show Uncle Bill crackin burger aka crack
how you feeling good hey thanks for
having you guys great titled me right
now he'll be [ __ ] pissed
hi never so what was really wild and I
think a lot of people that have listened
to the episode with you'll remember we
talked about this notion of teams and I
had never heard about this before that
you guys are not competing against the
casino you're competing with other teams
to get the line where you want it and I
thought of this world and I didn't know
and then I watched action and I see you
guys in New Jersey together kind of
going over a titans bet and hitting a
line early and you had all the analytics
and you were kind of looking for those
white spaces and boom I saw it with my
own two eyes how long have you guys been
working together doing this I would say
about a decade all right Wow yeah I
didn't think it was I thought it was
like a year or two it's actually pretty
quiet we're actually pretty quiet about
it but now so that that's not there no
more now everyone knows oh yeah did you
feel like you had to be quiet before now
you don't have to be I just you know I
really don't think so and you know as
you could see there I'm actually helping
people to they're getting a better line
that are following this howling warrant
on the NFL games yeah No
so how did you guys first meet through
someone else in Vegas that I was working
with and he's saying this guy wins in
the NFL which that's what I say
and I sat there and watched the first
year and you know you won like 20 you
know it sounds like I'm just sitting
here watch all these games just this guy
that I'm friends with told me this guy
went and I still didn't bet his stuff
yeah
and and then the next year we had a
really good season and we just every
year we would just keep going
can you explain to the normal Joes why
it's so hard to bet the NFL that's any
given Sunday anything it happened it's
the old adage what everyone talks about
yeah it's a hundred percent true every
single Sunday people shake their head
and say how can that have possibly
happened two years ago I talked about it
and there was 214 points the underdogs
that won outright one was the Giants
over Denver I figure what the other one
was for the two big dogs won outright
Denver was like four no and the Giants
were like oh and five they're playing
yes
and the Giants games that week though I
mean think about that I lost how can
that happen how can two double-digit not
just 10 or 11 14 plus point favorites
both lose just like this year Buffalo
beat Minnesota people were like a high
loss especially Warren and I we had
under I don't know if you realize more
you had under seasoned wins on Buffalo
what you told me to go bad at the South
when I think about under seven yeah I
got I'm sick I'm thinking oh man this is
easy I really did I said this is gonna
be easy because they started out like
Owen yes I'm playing a beat in a soda
yeah and I didn't ever tell you to this
you're gonna hear for the first time
here I was like oh my god don't tell me
that now this is gonna get them the pump
they're gonna be pumped up now and start
winning games and beat us on this bet
that were a huge mathematical favorite
to begin with also that we got the great
premiere number of seven with them is
six and a half even six and now we're
gonna have a chance to lose this because
now the momentum is going to be for
Buffalo to start winning games and there
was a chance that this could have landed
six and even even seven so we get upset
Barnes after that game no upset never
know I don't get upset at losses or
anything like that even if I lost it
didn't matter
I mean long-term it's all long-term so
he's watching you from afar and you have
this great season what did you think of
crack the first time you met him you
gotta be honest warrant ya know it was a
crazy story so I'm not that crazy but it
was intimidating so I go he called me up
and he's like come out to Las Vegas and
and me meet up with me and I said well
I'm going to be out there for I think
that was back when it's called like the
Las Vegas Hilton super contest register
for that
and and so I went out there he's like
hey you know I'll call let's get
together for dinner you know so I said
okay great and he he's like hey I'll be
out in front of your hotel I got a black
Escalade and I was like man what what's
good is this am I gonna be getting like
this guy gonna take my computer together
like you know so I go down there and I
was like a little nervous and then he's
if you're on his good side and and I
mean you could tell he's like one of the
nicest guys ever felt that way yeah
first when I learned I know your
computer yeah you rolled up on a black
Escalade he had no idea yeah that's why
I mean I literally carry my bag with my
computer everywhere I go because I don't
want to yeah anything is not gonna steal
my computer brother
Wow yeah but there it was the Escalade
more than oh man actually we ate dinner
with uh I believe it was Jim my property
yeah he came out and we I forget the
place but he's very cynical he believes
that no one could beat things to I mean
you guys were grilling me pretty good it
was good what kind of questions do you
ask someone to see if what they have is
valuable
I get everything I just had someone send
me a thing oh my god I beat the I didn't
tell you I had someone email the other
day and show me you're literally a
spreadsheet I beat the NFL every year
you know okay you know like these guys
everyone says they win at different
things and I just from your voice after
meeting you and stuff I just said
alright maybe you do tell me what do you
have a model do you have a an algorithm
or legal you are you going by personal
opinions and you know everyone thinks
they win for summer it keeps them coming
back if they didn't think they'd win why
would they come back it's almost the
definition of insanity it's the same
things over again it's the same reason
people don't track their spending right
they don't download the app to see where
they spend their money because they
don't want to see that seamless is 40%
of their salary
oh yeah you know what I mean so just
it's safer not to look that way you're
always winning that's my one leak you
just hit it besides food my leak I don't
drink smoke or do drugs but I definitely
don't keep track of spending I know and
ridiculous amount every month I don't I
don't know why I just I like to get what
I want do what I want my buddies
it so do you guys have a team name no
should we come up with a team name right
now sharp crack or cracks pretty awesome
yeah crack the sharp crack the sharp
sharp crackers yeah these are all good
is it are there more than just you guys
just and I felt just him really now I
saw in the show you had on your screen
it was like a spreadsheet and it's sort
of highlighting the inefficiencies is
that something you created that you guys
both monitor I think you're talking
about the odd screen I have my own best
screens the premium screen that looks at
that shows you all the different sports
books and what their lines are for all
the different games and you can look at
aeneas intensely you can look at first
half 1st quarter
you know team totals full game you can
just hit a key and jump exactly to those
lines and any time the book moves in
real time it's going to update on the
app so or the the programs that you're
able to track where the lines are and
what the best line is and that's what
his like literally his number one job is
is to find the best numbers and get down
my question is the timing because on the
show it seemed like you walked into a
book on a Sunday morning and you knew
the top 50 things that interest you
when do you guys decide these are our
plays and we're ready to go and we're
gonna monitor this throughout the day
but Wendy when do you provide the
information then you provide the
analysis is that the relationship it's
it's well first of all it's constant
right like I'm running my model to
figure out where the value is as soon as
the lines are coming out and then we
have to wait a little bit until the
market matures enough so that I mean cuz
some books one random offshore book will
open Sunday night
if you try to bet there first of all
you're not getting anything down and
then you're gonna destroy the market for
one more book sopra you have to it's it
takes a little while like years to
figure out exactly when we should be
timing the market well then during the
course of the week I mean we're in
constant communication throughout the
week multiple times a day discussing
some of the games and then sometimes
I'll ask him do you think we should go
on this or do you think we should wait
sometimes yeah yeah well
times wrong question there's indicators
in the market that people don't know and
there's certain indicators I know that
most people don't know so I have to know
if something ticks somewhere I know it's
about to go red everywhere and
everyone's starting to move so in the
beginning one like you said when that
one offshore line comes up the people
start to copy
sometimes I'll even try to manipulate
and bet the opposite way and some of the
originating guys so they think hey
cracks bet in that way I don't want to
ever tip my hat and let the middle
exactly what I'm betting yeah cuz then I
can't get that get down as much money on
my stuff you know would you say it's
like once a week where you bet one side
to eventually bet the other much more
really yes like five times
probably wow that's a good note I think
what's interesting about it is I read
your blog I've checked out your site you
have an app the name of the app is crack
wins
crack wins so everybody should check
that out in addition to sharp football
sharp sharp football recorder with that
though you say I am NOT just a gambler
like this is my profession I take it
serious and this is what you guys are
doing that is the difference is not just
the knowledge of seeing how the lines
typically go but those indicators and I
get worried about all the regular Joe's
that think they're professionals and
they're not because even listen you guys
talk about those that that part of it I
go no one else is doing that I don't
even consider myself a gambler here's a
gambler last night I was in the Lake
City with my assistant and is that they
wanted to go to the crap table it
physically and mentally bothered me that
I had to take 300 hauls out of my pocket
and put it at the crap table at negative
Evie but I said let me have some fun
with the guys but it's so crazy how I'll
gamble on something like that and then I
think my regular life I mean I spend
$300 on dinner every night like it's so
weird how I would relate that but I
forgot no dollars the crap table is
negative Vivi but sports wagers you say
it's not gamble it's not gambling to me
I know I have an edge a mathematical
edge on each game two three four five
percent and I know in the end all that
money I put through the window times the
x factor of the number it's gonna equal
a certain amount so even if I lose I
know it doesn't matter it's coming back
it's a return when this first hit you
well that particular patent of that
notion that no Asian and
that's because that's the moment when
you go I can make this my career 20
years ago yeah probably
they're late one day in the late 90s III
knew this was this wasn't the thing for
me I knew this was you know I know we
win long I know we were winning I was
winning every month I never had I was
having winning months now granted I may
have like one when I think we have one
losing month yeah and I have losing
weeks like I said I do have a losing
month but I knew that how much money I
was making compared to my regular job I
worked a ton of jobs a ton I come from a
blue-collar very hard worker yeah East
Coast family worked on a boardwalk
growing up my whole side crab fries
I'm telling exactly stuff like that
chicken peach crab sauce right exactly
right yeah I worked I did a couple
pizzas at a pizza stand I worked in you
know a games of truly listening to
before him because this was 10 years so
who are you listening to a 90 in terms
of I did my own stuff I did my own my
own spreadsheets my own my own power
ratings power charts I did and I end to
be honest we guy built up a bankroll
just middle thing and scalping back you
could you know but this is back at the
beginning of the Internet so you can bet
you know one guy and go over you know
200 our game and one there 240 not 214
yeah like to 206 or something I mean it
was really crazy betting different
markets back then it was so different
there was places on Australia like can
bet Canterbury downs who had their own
wine set over there and I was at the
stratosphere I remember which the
stratosphere just opened in Vegas okay
and the stratosphere was had a very
aggressive marketing campaign 105 juice
on everything so I remember that weekend
I was middling some of the college
basketball totals I said wow this is
unbelievable this business it was like
my second trip in Vegas and I was like
this is this is sick why do I feel like
you guys talk more than you talked to
like your wife oh I do know it's true I
mean I football season he talks to me
more he talks to his wife whatever yeah
and I do too
absolutely I know I just you know I feel
like you guys [ __ ] love it like I
feel like it's so much fun it's it's the
cool thing about it is it's a challenge
and this is what we were talking about
on the show the last time is that I feel
like crack my eye I don't really tell I
haven't talked to him about this I don't
think maybe I have but the real
competition like we're better than the
sports book I I don't think that's too
and out isn't safe you see all people
like me say as men a sports book Vegas
always wins the real competition is the
other betting groups that are gonna try
to beat us to the numbers and that we
have to try to make sure that we're
getting the best value because one of
the worst feelings for him is us waiting
too long to go on a game and missing a
number that's one thing that he doesn't
like more than even losing probably
absolutely it's getting the value and
that's where we have to try to
understand like all not quite like as
much as I'm handicapping the game yes
but a pretty good amount is what are
these other guys betting what have they
been betting so where would this line
probably head and when do we need to get
into I know that you don't sleep a lot
on Sunday night and I know you're
running all your models and all that
stuff what time do you get your
information to crack and then you guys
start and you have your own information
when does that first talk as early as
Monday for for the upcoming weeks I mean
we get down on some games on Monday for
the next Sunday's game right right but
if it's like Oracle II it's if it's if
it's a really off number and you know
this is like this is a discussion that
we have often like this number is bad we
can't get down quite as much as we want
to but this isn't gonna stay you know
these groups are going to hit it so if
we want to take advantage of it we're
just gonna have to go ahead and do it
right now so on occasion Monday but
Tuesday's generally the day that I've
got a lot of my you know I've got a good
understanding of injuries by then and
because Sunday the games happened yeah
you don't necessarily know the outfall
of injuries and how that's going so even
I mean the first injury report doesn't
come out till Wednesday it's so much a
killer you you you you but all
throughout the week
I mean we're exchanging information
talking on the phone going back do you
really read articles or like listen to
what coaches say does that even matter
really it's very it's it's definitely
important it's definitely important um
there are guys who I know for some of
the other stuff that crack does who are
just readers you know that's what they
do all they do is they don't have levels
they don't of it they all they do is get
information off the internet the press
conference social media so those random
local reporters like Katherine Terrell
that covers the
bengals there's someone that basis i
really something better oh yeah even say
but I'm gonna give it to you yes you
wouldn't believe what these individual
players coaches and especially assistant
coaches put on their own social media
put on their own Twitter following put
on our own Instagram you wouldn't
believe the stuff that they put like
nuggets of information you can get
before the wine makers get them we're
just having a full time person hanging
them just to read that stuff look I feel
the same way about I'm doing the left
coast show social media and I was like
if I could have one person that just
followed every single player in the NFL
and every day went through all their
social media I mean we're gonna find
viral videos all the time that people
don't even know exist but you're looking
at from a gambling I'm just a there's
three more I'm a Googler saying that
don't you so you know it's free content
yeah it's it's everything is the
information what's funny if you haven't
seen action you get to the window and I
notice that the bookies will literally
go
what's he bitten and then it can
completely change the line is that
what's the power feel like to be able to
do that when you guys go this is our big
play and then it moves do you guys feel
powerful I got a taste I'm we really
don't have any big place but yet
warrants had to unit plays which is very
rare once a year or even 0 times a year
and I really don't remember losing one
how about that I really I don't never
losing a 2-star to unit play anyway but
yeah sure I said it on action half the
high is actually knowing I'm gonna get
to a window or get to my app and change
the line and have the more power than
the bookmaker has because they don't
want me in their bedding oh my god this
guy what it was crackin burger the
better you know like if you showed up to
one casino for an entire season that was
your spot yes is it possible that the
bookmaker could be let go because
they're like your lines have been so off
that we're getting attacked and that's
their an intelligent bookmaker not if
they're a bookmaker like the guys at
like MGM or Caesars is they hate cracker
burgers given as a bet they gave me a
certain amount so you just give me five
thousand on total and Bell Tolls give
him
five thousand bucks we know to over move
the line get the customer on the
opposite side of the line I'm betting
over 46 let's not go to forty six and a
half let's go to forty seven bang now
they only gonna get under money but they
know a forty six is going to be hit and
the line is gonna I'm gonna actually bet
where the wine without a doubt for that
five thousand dollar investment I'm
actually gonna make the money in the end
but when you have small minded groups
like William Hill who throws anyone out
with a pulse that wins right away they
say oh we don't want that he wins get
him out of there or you know there's
people like leaving stations they threw
me off their app I had places like
places that cut me down so much like
it's not even worth it for me to bet I
go on to the win I can't why not use
your information dollars five thousand
all I want about two thousand dollars at
William Hill 1,000 bucks I wanna bet
they don't want it it's for a Caesars
company now oh sure ports a Caesars go
wow I didn't even know that you guys
good Preston give us users good Preston
if you know they're one of the greatest
they take bets off me well without a
doubt without a doubt I feel like South
Point seems to be like the better the
wagers favorite casino right now
I like South Point I like what they do
there just feel like everyone likes
listen look what they did during March
Madness the old Vegas Vegas thing was
hey the Vegas line I was always telling
people there is no Vegas line it starts
off short
CR is Chris Costa resident in Costa Rica
in international sports that's where the
line originates and everyone copies it
not during March Madness South Pointe
came up with the lines first
without a doubt and said hey crack if
you wanna bet us first we're gonna give
you all the games ten thousand a game up
to ten thousand a game and you could bet
it as each team was announced that's
Sunday night's election Sunday you can
bet them all and then they change their
lives you're a sick [ __ ] no I mean they
know that's amazing it's amazing I give
that I give South Point the credit there
that's unbelievable no one does they had
lines up before the offshore sports
books yes South Point I give them a ton
of credit
well the other thing South Point did for
the season win totals is you know I
identified some games some games that we
wanted and trouble for the NFL season
for last year the past year not this
year yet identified games that we wanted
to hit and Buffalo was one they they had
a number that was off right seven yeah
and a lot of other spots
six and a half so I was like we got to
get down to south and have a good bet
I'll take this there there limits were
three dimes right on that and crack
asked I want more than that and they
gave him five me five thousand yeah I
was cool I'm like great number they
don't normally give that to all the
people but because of the relationship
they increase their limit even though
they knew that he was betting a game now
hear all that story yes I listened to
Warren say that on a podcast on his
podcast I don't think I've told you this
and he was saying that South Pointe
actually has him at seven and I was
happened to be in Atlantic City that
weekend and I went and I said I'd like
to take the under of the bills please
they say oh it just got moved down to
six
and so I [ __ ] pushed but but it was
because he said that yeah so I was this
[ __ ] jamoke that got it at sixth but
I wasn't the word jamoke I love me but
but for me it was like I looked at the
bills and it was Josh out at the end of
the season made it Harry yeah he was
that impactful that it's well as a
runner that's I don't I think it was the
game against the Vikings that he first
hurdled the guy Lance Kendricks I
believe yes he hurdle Kendricks and that
was when I ran Eric Hendrix's brother
okay and and everybody's like whoa you
know this this guy's gonna run in the
open field
his teammates loved it yeah and Sean
McDermott is a good coach he's a very so
you know he's he's keeping that team in
games yeah that and then they did just
enough offensively to they're also an
amazing pick under Sean McDermott on the
road the last few years early in the
season just because defense always
dominates early in the season all right
where I want to do NFL win totals sort
of towards the end one other thing I
took from the show that I have to talk
about is crack bets
how many bets do you think you make on a
Sunday total like the quantity of them
well on a Sunday is actually a slower
day believe it's a slower day because
Saturday is the major day with the
college filet especially when it's
crossover with football basketball how
about a week how many bets total in a
week the win is when all of the leagues
are going it's against everything that
everyone ever talks about they they
always say the bookmakers say ah you bet
the more bet you make them we eat the
more money you're gonna lose out if the
percentages are not respected it's the
more money the more it's for the window
times that X Factor yeah is the
I'm gonna make in the end so I've got a
lot of games we talking like 100 200
bets yeah yes 100 yes so my question
would be this is what people don't they
haven't seen the show you don't watch
the [ __ ] games
no like very rare I will bet on a game
and then I will sit there for three
hours and I will scream and I will yell
and after I win I'll go nuts if I lose
I'm in a funk but you don't even watch
what happens when you're in that funk
what happens the end of the night what
do you do well I don't chase you don't
know good man I smoked a daddy cigar and
I got my fiancee and I go life is good
oh really Wow Wow
I guess I just eat like [ __ ] right I'm
like I'm gonna reward myself with awful
food right right right yeah no no IIIi
don't watch the games because you know I
just have it I don't know who I have if
I even walked by a screener oh maybe I
had that on the feather hmm so I'll get
the final score and I have two guys that
work for me you know and they watch
every game every single so but there has
to be a reveal so what is your reveal
are you just like updating your apps or
like do you look at a spreadsheet at the
end on Sunday night at the end of every
night including Sunday night yeah check
every night and you know what that's
what your reveal is it like you see the
total win-loss total and then that's
your moment where you're like ah I don't
really do that that's weird
I probably should though but I don't
equal II though I don't do that but I
don't get upset either when I lose it's
okay yeah you know I mean well I've
losing days that we lose a lot of money
too I'm sure six figures believe it or
not I've had those days but I've had
days winning that much so what was the
biggest L you've ever taken ah whether
it was one game a day for the day or for
a game and if you remember teams and
what was involved that's more fun for
everybody I definitely know what I'm
sorry I know things but definitely had
losing days where as a conglomerate as a
group have lost over a hundred grand for
sure we've had more of those days that
we won that much though what are the
phone conversations like when that
happens um pretty level-headed I mean
yeah I would listen
I was in the last day of the cancer
contest was a half-a-million-dollar day
it's either it's a winner-take-all half
a million dollar win this is a contest
about ten years ago case came down to
the last game of the day and what are
you wagering I still didn't watch NFL
it's NFL NFL we wound up going 48 and 20
Souls like the super cuts I said I got
this half a million winner-take-all that
was probably the biggest decision of the
day for I'm sorry of my life ever was
winning that half a million dollar
contract won it yes what was the game
Pittsburgh verse Cleveland and I
remember they were gonna sit someone
Pittsburgh was sitting something
supposed to sit somebody and the idea
behind a contest actually is not only to
pick what you want Helle Holcomb [ __ ]
[Music]
sorry no it's okay but the idea of a
contest is to put to find out what
people the other people in the contest
pick throughout the year actually do a
little literally look at all their stuff
that they did throughout the year and
try to determine what they're on more
than what I'm on my bet is gonna be my
bets are gonna be based on what they're
doing it's like a poker to you sometimes
you'll have to actually catch up so
you'll have to even pick games you don't
want but you try to figure out hey this
guy bets doing on every week I have to
bet the other side like yeah I have to
gain two games on them so we didn't have
to do that we were in first literally
from week six till the end but now we're
rolling in first by one game and don't
you know it came down to the last game
of the season half a million dollars on
one game and yeah would you during the
game remember I know I actually watched
a little no I did that Dorn that there
in the show though that was real till
they followed me to yeah well you got a
manicure during the Superbowl was no
playoff game play yes and charger yeah
you know I was gonna actually watch the
game with them I came up with that
suggestion I said listen I'm not
watching the game you guys want if you
guys wanna I know they want to film
different things like that but I don't
watch games why well I'm not gonna act I
didn't act there everything was real
nice yeah they follow me around so they
set up where we'll follow you're doing
your manicure okay great I want to say
something and then I want your guys
initial reaction up where I'm gonna go
to you first
Vegas Dave
crack Vegas Dave are you gonna say
anything
I I'm speechless another wine otherwise
no one has VD by the way oh that's good
for those that didn't see the show I
very much enjoyed his character because
he doesn't impact me like he impacts you
guys in the perception of like the
betting industry and all that and so for
me to see this guy that seemed like a
snake oil salesman that's going on
Instagram and going I've hit two long
shots in my entire life and that's the
track record that I need to convince you
to bet with me and then like completely
have no system whatsoever and and really
be taking so much money and it's this
belief where because people are paying
me I know what I'm doing and those two
thoughts are not actually intertwined
was fascinating to watch and I know that
he's facing some legal troubles right
now and as a human I hope that it works
out for him but it was fascinating to
watch this guy to see you guys with like
your computers and your your algorithms
and all that and then to see him go oh
yeah I knew that was gonna happen and
get saved by like that miracle touchdown
I was like shut off look that was
absolutely a miracle touchdown North
Carolina versus Syracuse yes and they
were always like to watch this what was
like for you to watch the dichotomy
between what you guys do and what he
considered me I didn't even know he was
on the show till it was done filming I
doubt if he if you knew I listen I I was
really adamant about after this was over
I was so mad I called the producer the
director the assistant producer they
were so nice to me that they act they
that night they called me from New York
man and on a four-way call on a
conference calling like crack calm down
and I was like calm down do you know I
have a reputation to protect you don't
to be associated I went crazy I over I
went overboard like my wife was grabbing
me like calm down I went knock I just
didn't know how to show and I didn't
even know what he was what he was gonna
I didn't know what happened I didn't
know if he won or lost not even knowing
they were like listen just please let it
play out you'll see and and and we did
we actually did let it I did let it play
out and it did turn out in their favor
it worked out perfect for you great if
the charges would have beat the Patriots
and wind up in the Superbowl Vegas Dave
would would make millions off the show
which I'm sure he still made a lot of
money off the show and you said
you broke it down you seen exactly where
the ferry was coming from
listen I use a $500 premium down best
feed $500 a month he's using free
outdated lines that are you know and
saying all like that one that one just
moved that's the one we're gonna go with
guys like that's the extent of his work
really scared me yeah for like the
normal people out there that are right
looking for someone to give them answers
right and who knows what that could have
cost them he's a great talker though
he's a great salesman last night I went
to dinner with someone and he's like
listen he's a great salesman what he
does I can't do that I can't go on I
can't jeopardize myself not only
jeopardize myself internally I can't do
it I'm not that person I'm a product of
my parents and my parents race
my parents didn't raise me to be like
that yeah this guy took seven hundred
thousand off his parents I made thirty
forty thousand dollars a year the whole
life savings working for fifty years and
he took all their money to bet on
different things and what they what they
don't show their yeah when I was mad
about originally was they let him talk
and say you know I'm not allowed in the
casinos because I win no no Dave that's
not why you're not allowed not allowed
in the casino cause she used faked ID
and you committed a fraud family that's
why what he was just told yeah yes he
got sentenced this month but he's like
hey he's not gonna he's just gonna get
preneur something and and listen I don't
want him in jail no I wouldn't do I mean
I would not do well in jail Oh first
Lauren wouldn't Warren might do well in
jail Warren's like one of those guys
were like someone please give me your
lunch then Warren turns around and like
knows how to turn into nunchuck somehow
oh wow I think Warren like received a
mustache I think Warren's a secret
assassin yeah
I'm waiting for Warren to turn yeah and
just like breaks the table superhero it
all comes out yeah yeah but yeah so
anyway listen I hate to so you like the
guy sounds like you like I'm not saying
they're always stating facts yeah my
main thing with Vegas Dave is to protect
people at home and and the the under 35
crowd that actually gets impressed by
these fancy cars the girls the the
lifestyle the living to be just but if
you're a little bit common sense a
little bit street smart you see what he
said I
have no friends I don't have a
girlfriend he said I have no friends
there's my only friends are my wife I'm
sorry my dog and his parents that's what
he said
so he just doesn't if you look at him oh
no I gotta go we got a good look at him
if you look at him heat you could Syria
there's this there's a lot of things
going on there you know I don't think
you have anything to add to that do you
bored yeah yeah I I agree with
everything crack said pretty much yeah
we we were a little surprised that he
was actually on the show I think that
was the biggest thing for us you know I
I didn't have a lot of communication
with the news just like crack did
because he was doing so much for them
and organizing the show and and and and
helping out and with introductions and
that sort of thing so you know he did a
lot to make that she was the guy with
the hairpiece that lived to the casino
no one knows him he's a big gambler I
heard in the casino but he claims to be
a big wet NFL winning player and listen
well a lot of the bets that he made on
camera worked out they did and if
anyone's allowing you to bet 50,000 on
futures and 50,000 on games you can
guarantee there's a reason why they're
letting you bet there oh do you know
you're not allowed about that much no
way
impossible that and that's and I love
that place by the way I love the West
Gate I love the guys at The Whisky you
know why those are the sharpest
bookmakers in town themselves really
their betters they bet those guys so but
those guys aren't going to accept fifty
thousand on futures from me I can
guarantee it right well that means a lot
yeah cuz all the ones they showed him
yeah chief sweat in the West and he had
he had the Rams to win and he had the
real Super Bowl he hedged it a little
bit at the Animus pre surprise but and
he got he actually have you ever heads
before
um very rare never I make a bet that's a
positive V V bet to head you making a
negative V V bet yes now your language
is well if you you know you should only
hedge if you over bet or if there's an
injury or something you see that maybe
they didn't see if you're watching the
game yeah so no I don't hedge a lot of
times we would talk about some of the
games because we were that's one of the
good things about getting done early and
knowing the market and having a good
model you're going to be on the positive
side of line moves most of the time so
the line value that we're getting on
most of our games is very good
is good - very good right and and so
there will be times when a line will
move multiple points and will like
should we should we do anything with
this and and generally the answer from
crack is why do I want to bet against a
great bet that we already have we
already have a great bet the line is
moved significantly in our favor why
would I want to go things we could win
both I mean our college my college games
sometimes move with 10 points and I
still don't hedge it I mean I literally
had some obscure stuff this past week in
arena football move 15 points after we
better I was literally about to say what
other sports - you bet and then you said
arena football and now I've realized
that we have tapped into the mother lode
I'm like so Warren you mainly do NFL you
only do NFL I do a little bit of college
total college - NFL's like my bread and
butter
now can you rank the sports for me in
terms of hardest to easiest to bet
because NFL the hardest all that and I
felt I'm gonna i'm going to say mba yet
this season i hit 58 % mb hey that's
pretty great so mba sides very tough to
beat NFL sides first toughest to beat
NBA sides tough to beat
and if l totals which warm beats every
season I think that's the toughest
that's that's the toughest three college
basketball college football college
basketball totals easiest to be really
college that's our totals yes are you I
feel like the college basketball engine
the common better always bets the over
do you would you say majority time bet
the under not really we used guess what
you're right for decade the under was
the way to go on almost anything you bet
because you're betting against the
public in any sport any capacity who
bets the under right however now
actually there's a lot of opportunities
that we actually will bet the over cuz
the bookmakers anticipation already is
for that under to be a sharper side Wow
they'll actually put the line where it's
skewed to the under and a lot of times
the over is the right way so that's the
advantage of doing this for so long as
seeing those waves of movement yes what
other sport what about like you bet
women's college basketball absolutely
WNBA
house WNBA Tibet excellent we I was
hoping you wanted to ask it it's very
very easy sport like that no women are
very consistent now like there's a
reason
Yukons like 40 like 96 and one yeah and
I tapped into something yeah you did
what about very limited markets now when
it first start when I first came out you
could bet college car perfect college
baseball baseball was you can get down
and we can get down five ten thousand on
a college baseball game now maybe two
dimes dimes dimes I mean yeah is it
because there's just not enough market
or because it's too easy to manipulate
not even manipulate there's no I'm going
to be late in there but I want to talk
manipulating to I only mean key numbers
in like in certain situations trying to
get it past a seven or so yeah you know
what I mean by key numbers but yeah
college baseball it's just there's just
more information out there than the
bookmaker has and I feel that that's
what we have we have more information on
everything I think we have better
information than the originating lie
makers and the bookmakers so college
baseball definitely what about a major
league baseball we started out
unbelievable two seasons so yeah we're
doing good we be baseball two years ago
I can't even - I've won more money in
one single sport that no one would
believe Major League Baseball two years
ago I I never see it sources because I
never believed it I've won a 200 units
in MLB that's sick I never won that in
college basketball was there a few teams
that were just like lining up perfect
that Magus wasn't seeing and we just are
what's funny is I don't even think you
care about the teams I think you just
see the units and the numbers you're
like oh 2016 yeah but you're not like I
hit the Padres for 70% of them or
something no no no but last year
basically we want 50 units so your
favorite team my bankrolls my allegiance
hmm that's it and I used to be a
favorite player I don't know yeah I
don't even know I have no favorite
player I don't want I actually kept in
crud I probably can't name five Yankees
and that's like the team's that I used
to follow when I was a kid the Yankees
and Mets I mean now there's no favorite
players but I yeah that's the only sport
I'll go to if you ask me to go sits
courtside with LeBron James game I
probably would hear about to get a
football team you're about to get the
race yes sit in a booth how cool would
it be you'll be the only guy in that
entire stadium whose back will be facing
the stands
and you can just be in one of those
Suites making bets I thought you can
actually make the bets right here your
sports apps ring but you'll be the only
one not watching the field right I won't
be watching
yeah I get you I get ya I won't even go
to the games though and I probably get
free tickets to that so easily but not
probably one of a go I mean like I said
a baseball game though I'll be happy to
take a ride to San Diego in Petco Park I
love going to watch a game in San Diego
yeah and you know sitting down for a dog
and a beer I mean all right so what are
four regular Joe's at home simple rules
that people can follow that you think
you're either misnomers or just little
things like one of yours would be don't
chase hmm what what else comes to mind
just to help everybody out there yeah
number one that's the number one
actually people get they can't control
themselves emotion gets in the way so
automatically when that late-game comes
they be they lost the other game is to
bet the tendency to bet the late game
and then if they don't win that the
money like that probably been Monday
Night Football to get out that's the
worst thing that's why the old
bookmakers in New York they used to
close the week on Monday not Sunday so
the week now a week goes from Monday to
Sunday but years ago the New York
bookmakers they used to go literally
close the week on a Monday so Monday
night that's when we settle after Monday
next they know everyone would chase and
you know they just chasing loose
that's the number one thing bankroll
management this is something that hardly
anyone follows you cannot be a winning
better even if you have great
information if you're over betting your
bankroll because there's gonna be those
swings and there's gonna be those those
streaks where you're gonna have losing a
losing week or so you have to bet 1 to
2% I know it sounds weird 1 to 2% maybe
3% of your bankroll so if you have a
$10,000 bankroll that's a lot of just
for a bankroll manage us for sports
betting yeah not to eat dinner Adams not
to run day in and out bird run touch
this is untouchable just for that you
could bet the most you give it a $300
per game it's hard to do because in
every sport you go wherever you go
you're gonna see someone have a thousand
dollars in their pocket the whole
thousands in action
you can't win that's why those buildings
are there that's a very very important
thing and and that's gonna right but
that's gonna but that's gonna get bigger
you often 10 to 20,000 interest now you
can have 600 600 on the game that's how
I see you know when I started with $1000
that was your first bag thousand bucks I
five hundred bucks a to offshore
sportsbooks Gary Bowman in England and
English sports betting down down in
Jamaica that's where I started
that's exactly where I started 25 years
ago and that's you know you just build
up oh by the way it's and that's go
ahead they give you they give you
bonuses till they could they give me
they match the bonuses like New Jersey's
doing now I know I'm going off subject
but like please go to Jersey you take 20
grand and before you start betting
you're gonna have 24 grand I mean they
just give you a bonus they need people
to get a European way European these are
European books that are that are booking
PokerStars on points bet points that
right now is the best one than 105 juice
on NBA and NFL they had zero juice on
the championship game oh by the way if
you deposit ten grand we're gonna give
you another thousand bucks just to start
I mean they that's just a sick promotion
that they have that and that's that's
exactly that's another big thing is
multiple outlets multiple outs to feel
better because you know for living you
know we're looking at the screen and we
can get down on pretty much every you
know the majority of the books that are
there some obviously cut cut them off
but the majority of books but if you're
a regular Joe and your regular Joe and
you're managing your bankroll like crack
said and you're doing the other things
that he's going to say the one key is
you got to have a few different spots
now that these books are offering
bonuses why the hell wouldn't you take
advantage of that and open accounts at a
few different places but inevitably some
of these guys are gonna have a
half-point different line here 10 cents
15 cents juice different there and
maximizing your ability to get that
extra half point without having to pay
for it or to get that savings in ten or
fifteen cents a juice is big I mean
that's what these guys live for because
it's only the volume so when you say 105
or it's 110 you're right actually
presenting I I just well one thing that
I've realized with my job is it's
important for me to ask the very simple
questions because I'm just at so many
questions like what's plus 220 yeah so
the juice I don't think that people
realize okay you have to bet if it's
minus 105 you have to bet 105 to win a
hunch correct so instead of 110 but I
think a lot of people go who cares if
it's five or ten dollars do
can you explain to them why that five or
ten or fifteen is
such a big deal your accumulative li
that means a lot so and normal sports is
fifty two point three eight percent you
have to in order to make money let's
just round it up but let's say fifty
three percent you have to you have to
beat two in order to make money
fifty three percent of your games
because you're having a bet more than
you're winning
however for someone like me when I like
Warren just said I have multiple outs so
I have different I get better at caesars
like a better than mg I make a better
Kanter so I have these different places
to bed at that all that lowers it now I
don't have to win fifty two and a half
percent no more fifty I can actually win
fifty two percent now I throw him out
105 juice places instead of 110 I'm
weighing 105 50 percent savings on juice
now I'm down to 51 and a half or 51 and
changed percent so that's a lower
percentage and that I have to win
compared to the average Joe so guys at
home why would you want to lay New
Jersey has it like I said that points
bet has 105 juice so if you instead of
playing 110 on a game if you bet 500
bucks and then you know you lose the
game you lose in 550 but you can only
lose 525 now you know here you have 20
more games and you got a free bet more
words you know so it's a factor it is no
because you usually someone that's a
Sunday warrior is going to one casino
they I don't matter and you know I love
people that say this to you don't pay
juice if you lose well that's not you're
gonna lose though I mean yeah you're not
gonna keep winning yeah to what you were
saying about having multiple options I
was reading this book originals by Adam
grant and they were this one company was
having an issue of hiring and they
couldn't fatally try to do a study on
what is a discernible characteristic
that they could identify that could show
that these people are better hires and
they tried do they are they do they wake
up early in the morning or do they stay
up late like everything and they
couldn't find any statistics except for
one whether or not you used Internet
Explorer or Google Chrome or Firefox and
what they saw my it was like a 25% gap
that people that used Google Chrome or
Firefox were better workers and what
they they surmised it was because you
have something that works but there
is an option out there that is proven to
work better will you take the initiative
to download something that is free to
have a better experience or will you
just use what you already have and they
found that these people created jobs
they want moved up higher in their
company like we're actually more
go-getters by this one action and that's
what I thought about when you're talking
about willingness to go and look at
other books and go oh if we look here
here but a lot of people just go I
always go to South Pointe Caesars is
it's where I made my first bet that's
not how [ __ ] works but you guys are
willing to go the extra step to find
that guy a professional should be yes
any professional those half points means
so much you know a South Point could
have over forty seven and a half from
Warren and I look in the bed over and
Ceaser's have 47 well I would never bets
up my whole life is based on never
betting that forty seven and a half over
the 47 is the right thing to do and that
is the choice I'm going to have I have
to have those different multiple outlets
without a doubt my choice is always
gonna be I'll pass on a game I'll pass
on it if we can't get a game well even
he'll tell me man it was 47 or week it's
47 and a half now I'm just gonna pass
we'll pass on it oh yeah and other times
he'll be at a board just using this
example he'll be out South Point and
it's 47 and a half and I tell him here's
a game he's like well I'm at South Point
what is it well it's 47 a half there
well what is there any other better
number well yeah it's easier that's 47
all right well you're gonna have to wait
25 minutes because I'm gonna drive all
the way over there to get that number
like it's that important that he'll
drive all around town to get the right
numbers you can't do that online some
noises but they're gonna take in person
so they're gonna take five figures from
me on the app they're only gonna take a
certain amount not just a little
schmooze especially the other places too
cuz I have a seven-star car which is
their highest-rated Cardinals you know I
have credit line the teachers properties
I have a lot of credit lines there at
the properties they keep those credit
lines because that actually helps me get
larger sports bets down to dude I bet
you could see like Hello Dolly a
thousand times you have so much like
crazy yeah yeah no you're right I do I
have credit wise a lot oh I love that so
my guy Joe NRL
big wig here loves a good gambling eye
good wagering and I told me you guys
were coming on I said you know what
should I ask and he gave me a few things
I'm just gonna kind of give you a phrase
and you tell me what you think about it
double-digit favorites and dogs how do
you guys typically approach that I would
from an NFL yeah you you got a handicap
it the way that you handicap best game
by game basis game by game basis yeah
absolutely for me it's completely
completely rare that we're gonna lay
double-digit favorites yeah it really
doesn't happen all that often because of
the way that NFL is in ball bounce
different ways except maybe the Patriots
yeah I mean there's even a teams that
are there are certain teams that are
better than others but obviously as as
as you know but some of the listeners
may not know you think that this team is
so much better and they are and
especially early in the game they're
better but when you've got a big lead
and it's late and you no longer care
about trying to cover the game you just
know that you got the win locked up and
you got this other team here whose coach
is fighting for his job and trying to
come back that's when a lot of these
backdoor covers end up happening and so
you you really have to be careful that
you love the page handicapped and it
should be 11-point favor yeah you never
can like just base it upon that when
you've got such a wide margin of the
reason I love the Patriots I know it's a
he they're a true 60-minute team and
they get pissed at every score they're
the only team that operates like that
Jets Patriots last year I think they
were fair we're like thirteen and a half
and it was at like 14 and the Jets were
driving down and they had the Patriots
had a goal line stand up like 14 points
and I'm like no other team would really
care this much and Bill's over there
coach games over yeah he doesn't care
yeah um what about home dogs does that
excite you well let me go back to your
[ __ ] shirt I referred to Warren but
I'll just tell you something too I do a
lot of market capping what I mean by
that is I'll see the wine is 14
everywhere but yet Vegas because there's
so many people laying the double-digit
favorites goes to 14 and a half and 15
or better yet it's 13 11
Vegas goes to 14 and even for a second
they may go to 14 and a half or 14-20
where I'm getting plus 14 no juice just
based on that and nothing else you'll
take the point I will take the points
without even calling them up saying
anything to all because across the nose
I know that there's value there taking
that 14 and a half when there's 13
laughs on the sharper sportsbooks
offshore like pinnacle grande yeah he's
sharper sports books that I follow
offshore yeah I just know there's value
there so but however the opposite side
of that I'm probably never gonna lay -
double - just based on that home dogs
used to be great for Monday nights home
dogs it was a great system just but you
know everything's factored into the line
like so better defenses on Thursday
Night Football right this thing two
years ago well listen I kind of still is
a thing it's out there and the
originating bookmakers know that and the
things are usually factored into the
line so you're even you may even get an
extra half a point once in a while
because that information is out there so
again I'm gonna have to defer to Warren
really well Thursday night first of all
double-digit home favorites double did
your favorites have actually been been
crushing it the last several years real
against the spread they've been overall
they've been doing very good but let me
tell you that Thursday the biggest key
on Thursday is not necessarily the home
team it's the favorite because the team
that is better the team that is better
doesn't have to try to come up with the
crazy ways of trying to win this game on
short rest short rest so if you look at
it home teams have a good win win rate
on Thursdays but favorites even if it's
Road favored ends up having a better win
rate against the spread than even just
because they're naturally the better
team if you take for example like this
is a seven or eight point favorite if
you're a seven or eight point underdog
on the other side of that you realize
like hey we're the jaguars we're we're
not going to really be able to go up and
beat like the you know the Minnesota
Vikings just in a straight up so what
are we going to do what trick play what
wrinkles are we going to corporate when
you have a full week to prepare when you
only have three days and you're on
well you you can't really go outside the
box all that much it's more of a vanilla
type of a game plan and it's just more
difficult for those worse teams to
compete with the better ones do you put
a lot of stake into west to east or east
to west travel that's always a fun thing
that people like to talk about
yeah it's become less of a factor of
late simply because teams have adapted a
little bit more like the the sport
sciences come in a little bit more so
you know there used to be a big
disadvantage west getting the charge box
or something like that that was always
there playing at 10:00 a.m. right 10:00
a.m. body clock game but it's actually
not been quite as impactful as it used
to be in the past
I love realizing that certain things can
be antiquated and they were like a real
thing five years ago but that's how
quickly it can change but there's other
things I mean East going to West and
playing a night game right now there's a
circadian rhythm issues going on there
so there's there's a there's some other
angles to look at the England games
together going to England maybe coming
back you know the traveling and and the
other thing that some teams are doing
now that they weren't doing before is
intentionally staying out on the west
coast and they actually now the league
allows you to do this now you can
request us hey I know that I got to play
the Raiders in the Seahawk so can you
back those games up back-to-back
weekends for me this season and I'm just
going to stay on the west coast and
guess what the league takes that into
consideration a lot of time and we'll
book you know those team and let them do
that and so then the coach she says hey
you know I know week 13 and 14 we're
playing these two West Coast teams we're
just going to stay out here and so that
happens pretty frequently or teams that
are about West Coast teams that are
about to go to London the boys play all
right so they're doing more things the
league scheduling department is doing
more things I mean the league schedule
five six years ago used to be a disaster
in terms of the inequalities that it was
presenting across the league like this
year's interesting - well there's some
issues but there's not as many as what
there used to be like you used to have a
team like the Buffalo Bills I remember
like four years ago where the bills were
playing on short arrests than their
opponent like six games of the season I
mean that's that's almost half the
season that you're playing on Shore
arrests like some of the inequalities
but they've changed their scheduling
algorithm actually you know we know a
little bit about some of their
scheduling algorithm stuff and they
change the scheduling algorithm and it's
it's more equitable around the league
for teams now it is interesting because
this year I know the NFC East faces the
AFC East and the ase feast AS East also
faces the AFC North so the amount of
travel for those East Coast teams the
AFC East is like nothing like I think
New England like the Jets don't even
have to leave the East Coast all year or
something like that
it's wild yeah I mean those types of
schedules are great for for coaches
and-and-and players to some extent but
medical the medical team and and the
coaches they love it when you can have
situations like that where you don't
have to do a lot of travel because I
mean people don't realize it but the
little things matter you know if you get
if you get a guy who tweaks his knee
right and he's our East Coast guy and
they played out on the west coast and
he's got a home Thursday night game and
he tweaked his knee in Oakland and he
has to fly at altitude back I mean
swelling occurs on the plane flying back
and that's a factor then on a short week
trying to reduce that swelling as
whereas if he played on the East Coast
and didn't have a short week he might be
at a higher but I've always been I've
always thought that players can't really
impact the lines that much unless you're
like a quarterback like I've always seen
like Rainey can swing at seven and
Roethlisberger can swing at six and
Roger swings at eight so do you like how
do you balance not caring too much about
the injury report but also monitoring it
and seeing what's the deals gonna be
that's what that's where it's like a an
art it's not just a science it's a
science if you can say well this
quarterbacks worth X but I've seen in
the past articles written about
quarterbacks that are worth X I don't
buy into that because it depends who
you're playing on a given week as to how
much your quarterback is going to need
to perform if you are Tom Brady and
you're playing the Buffalo Bills okay
you don't need Tom Brady to do all the
things that Tom Brady typically does so
he's not worth quite as much against the
bills but if you're playing the Chiefs
and you need to score 45 points to be
competitive then
Tom Brady's worth even more that game so
it varies based upon your opponent as to
how many how many points of take on this
- on my side I always see sports books
over moving lines like this because the
public knows so with the anticipation
they'll move the game or over move the
game based on someone being injured
especially a key player let's go to
basketball like LeBron James yeah well
the guy that's gonna step into LeBron
James shoes can probably start on any
other NBA game NBA team so really after
the wine over moves the injured team
quote-unquote he's actually the right
side of a game more than more often than
lizards so also same thing with the NFL
and I felt someone oh my god he's not
gonna start this week Brady so it's
gonna that'll move the guy a game three
or four points and a lot of times it's
really not worth three or four points a
bad day quarterback is still a good
quarterback can play on most other teams
- when you're talking about guy like
Brady unless it's a team like the
Packers or the Seahawks where I feel
like or now the Chiefs where so much is
based on that one got like the Seahawks
without Russell Wilson are [ __ ] awful
like the Packers the am I speaking to
like no you're absolutely I think the
Rodgers can completely give he's not
there we've seen DeSean Kaiser like it's
alright it depends it depends totally on
what the number two is and the that's
why it's more of an of an art form
because you could try to say oh well Tom
Brady's were seven points in line but
one year you might have a good backup in
the next year he has an experienced
backup so everything's got to be more
fluid and that's why you really have to
study this scenario the opponent I mean
you're talking about like a running back
being worth how many points like not
very many yeah but some some of the
public might think that the running back
is pretty valuable right no look around
huh yeah hot girl he's so valuable well
guess what Sean McVeigh's great
coordinator and call and play caller and
so he's going to scheme things up and
right back up is going to do just as
well the running backs not as valuable
but guess what starting center everybody
doesn't care about the starting center
but but we're looking at oh my god yuck
they're there in their first game sorry
yeah you know that's a big deal touches
the ball of every play right but to
other to other to other like the common
public even like the regular mainstream
shows don't even gonna announce
this guy's injured it's like the gloss
it over the other thing too is like
cluster injuries you know you're dealing
with one cornerback who's out okay you
can who's the number two what opponent
are they going up against what's the
style of game going to be this is how
much we should wait this guy
well now you're dealing with two guys in
the secondary that are out so that's
gonna change like the one guys worth his
absence is worth a little bit more now
because the second guys out and now the
the third string guys to come in or like
they're missing both safeties in a game
so you're gonna really have to adjust to
what type of defense they're gonna play
and how good they're going to be at
rolling coverages and those types of
things
schedule comes out a few weeks ago did
you guys just pour over it right away I
I would think he'd you know just to let
you know I actually know the person who
puts the schedule out because I go to a
charity dinner he's there Howard catches
his name yeah
former do it for a long time former
president event ABC sports that job is
unbelievable how hard it is to put that
schedule that I've talked to him about
it sounds like there's millions of
combination and you're gonna upset
somebody exactly point exactly then to
Raiders and the team that are upset this
year right sure what was their situation
with the schedule offhand I don't
remember what their I just remember they
had like six games away from home in a
row oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they they
they had I think like two road games
then they had a London game then they
had a bye and then they went back on and
had two more road games it was something
like that so they weren't playing in
their home stadium for hey cuz their
game I believe their game in London was
a was a home game right he lost that
weight so they had this like just brutal
schedule stretch where they didn't play
any games at home yeah so that was there
is well you guys bet win totals now or
is there a time of the year where you
feel most comfortable maybe you're
asking that question just last night we
were going over them but we haven't
barely just some now or is that gonna
[ __ ] you up but we can't give anything I
didn't bet him yet so I mean it's nice
to help the public on everything but I
just yeah and we didn't even better mean
we could we could talk a little bit
about it I mean you want to give him
away give away no I'm not gonna give him
away right now I could say stuffing you
guys will just wink at me I I could tell
you okay so I've been tracking the wind
total since they were first released
right they came out before you get into
that yeah what is your approach to win
totals because I think
you look and you realize oh they're all
they're all mainly eights and nines and
stuff like how do you approach wind
totals like from a philosophical
standpoint well on the negative you're
tying up your money for a long time so
that's a big negative when you're
looking at placing a bet because you
could I'll give you an example Arizona
Cardinals five a couple books had five
and a half yes they also have a week one
game against the Detroit Lions they're
playing at home the line is Arizona plus
1 if you think Arizona might need to win
that game in order to get over 5 you
could just bet week one and not tie your
money up for the entirety of the season
right so there's others ways that you
can look at it but that's one negative
in terms of tying up your money of
course that long but you know you you're
gonna get bets that you think have value
when you can find him I mean I think we
went seven and one I was really on my
wind totals that I had last year and it
were the team's you bet do you mind can
we do Carolina Dallas Buffalo Seattle I
mean those were a number of the unders I
can't remember the teams that we are
betting overs on the bolts underneath no
Baltimore you Baltimore the cold is that
a loss
because I bet the Baltimore over I hit
that yeah yeah we were we were on the
overpass was Dallas right the loss was
Dallas last week ten minute first a
giant yeah seven and a half points we
should have won it like we had to
mathematically way game trying to win a
Super Bowl and dak had like seven
completions to Blake jar one or some
[ __ ] like that
and then and then the other thing that
we did which was which was great is I
wish they took more money on these was
some of the books Kanter will release
lines on weeks one to 16 they don't line
we've had have been wild we destroyed
them we asked why would they do that
hello give you more number one reason
number one reason marketing potential
they can say that they've got this and
then what it does if they're the only
book out there that has lines week 1 to
16
guess what if you're in
you're gonna have to go to Cantor if you
want to bet a week seven game Cleveland
versus the Indy now so what your book
that does so well Warren is you can look
at trends and oh they have a really
rough stretch towards the end of the
year or that middle time they face like
four easy run defenses in a row
will you they kind of look at that and
then go to a place like that and kind of
see a week fifteen this could be a
really rough stretch for the Falcons
here yeah absolutely I mean that's what
we were doing we were doing last year
the limits were only $500 which is like
nothing right what would happen look old
yeah see being Bill cracker never helped
us there we ever talked about this they
he liked the calls he thought they were
have a good year I started betting week
one week two now all of a sudden the
bookmaker cancer moved the hole every
single game they moved to half a point
to a point on it the rest of the year
Colts we only had five game circles of
the Colts
so they happened to be very early on but
but they they moved them all so now beam
bill crack of her actually a little bit
lucky but no one because if it wasn't me
they wouldn't I said I actually called
the guy that runs Cantor said listen I
could have put these all on the queue
together and just bang them all or went
there and just I could have circumvented
limits wedding there about 200 bucks 100
bucks 50 but a caught it I could have a
2,000 I'm trying to bet you guys
legitimately you can't just move all the
lines on me what I mean and they're
books that do that I will penalize them
I actually will go in under the cover of
darkness like Modell when he left
Cleveland I will do that and I will bang
you out of a lot more money than
originally if he just took the bet so we
had a little problem there and he moved
them all back for us he was your right
cracker I should give you a fair shake
and all the line so he was like they
found the Colts yeah they're the team I
was exactly in well if you remember okay
this is it was one of my labor cuts to
build the bills under and the Colts
because the whole public what were what
was everybody talking about june/july
Andrew Luck's not even throwing a
football
Andrew Luck's gonna be terrible will he
ever even be back that was one of the
biggest storylines it was all of off
season last year he wasn't because of
what happens in a year before I was one
of those guys going
he's only throwing with the tennis ball
he's throwing with the college not a
real football at all and so and so I was
like look at this this is creating
massive opportunity because I think the
dude's going to be okay
and so we started but you know we I
circle we bet the Colts over in the
season win total we bet the Colts on a
number of these games and of course like
like crack said like they surtseyan in a
sharp account the accounts flagged so
they're seeing he's betting the Colts
win total he's betting the Colts week -
he's betting the Colts week before like
let's move all these Colt signs so we
were getting like +5 they moved it down
to plus two and a half you know
ridiculous I would not and so we had
that you'll see a motion get involved I
get a motion involved when I'm trying to
do something legitimately and legally
and and doing it for you transparently
so you can adjust your settings and now
you want to screw me on stuff then the
bane of my existence becomes discrete
you change the lives that you had
already bet like that's not possible but
they're trying to put down a future in
other words week 12 13 14 sort of moving
everything on the culture because hey
they say cracks gonna Bend anyway let's
give him a worse line and I was just
trying to do it legitimately 500 bucks
where I could have actually met more
money so that's where they're doing what
they call moving on air they're not
actually taking a bet on the week twelve
game they're just predicting that
they're wrong on the Colts and and
correct document maybe like the guy said
admitted I believe were probably wrong
on the Colts now that he saw all of the
bets that we were making our Colts and
so that's why they made those moves
ahead of time before they even took
action on it we scooped by the way one
thing when I five I know on the Colt
games I know just just one thing I kept
a spreadsheet and I looked at all the
bets that were in for the that were on
the weeks 1 to 16 lines what lines we
got versus once that game got there week
30 yeah it was it warm asteroid them
were like seven points do you remember
any of them towards in I my hard drive
it was it was humorous
looking back on them but you know those
were the opportunity situations where
it's um what I what distinctly remember
one and one time only that I call
cracked the line and move like seven
points I was like crack you know the
this is ridiculous like should we do
something here and and then he was like
it's just 500 bucks like we're not gonna
sweat it till he takes nickels yeah so
I'm yeah you know not that I'm not
that's a lot of money for a lot of
people
fashion online yeah that's recreational
yeah completely different yeah
the I was gonna get an anaphor we have
so much fun on this show this is
actually a fun show yeah I mean I just
have two questions actually around this
is the kind of discussion I've never
I've never had this before I've only
gone one-on-one so this is this is your
follow me I'm your first yeah this is
fun Oh anyway yeah it's first through
but in terms of oh so futures all that
stuff [ __ ] I don't know look what the
wind totals this year and we're kind of
look at him what you guys do really well
is not letting emotion oh this is what I
want to ask do you ever see news stories
going off the Andrew Luck stuff where
everyone's like man Antonio Brown got a
gold moustache is crazy but you're
actually seeing the matrix like you're
seeing how this could impact betting
like how this could actually well if the
public's really interested in him going
to Oakland maybe that's gonna draw more
attention oh you know I mean like do you
see stuff like that too with normal
stories yeah I mean the public / one of
the biggest things that is a factor in
like a consistent thread through
everything that we do is public
perception right I mean we're constantly
trying to understand a process public
perception now because I would say right
now in terms of this the Browns are the
public team right
like I would assume that their win total
of nine at least that's what I'm seeing
in Caesar's right now it's my gut would
say bet the under just because I would
imagine that all the casinos are gonna
make their win total higher because
everybody loves the brown excellent
perception yeah 100% spot-on good yeah
good no it is because even like I
noticed some sports books don't have
season wins yet but they only have
Cleveland Browns over-under season wins
they just feel like America's team
that's right yeah you're absolutely just
the Browns up that's it nothing else so
yeah it is crazy I'm worried about this
one this is another one I like I see
this Bill's right here at six and a half
there this team six and a half and last
year's team was also six and a half that
doesn't make [ __ ] sense to me well I
can tell you the
like I mentioned earlier looted - I've
got a spreadsheet where I'm looking at
what the book opened at and where some
of the new books are opening or where
the books have moved like you know the
the Westgate just opened seizures opened
with arrows what like a week ago I
believe there's their season with who
came out April 29th okay yes he's Monday
and and then like I think canter was the
first ones out and and Southpoint just
came out as well South Pointe came out I
think yesterday I got a email that South
Pointe was out so now we see some of the
books that were open before now the
current books and the Buffalo Bills
based on my numbers here are the team
that their win total has moved the most
towards the over since the original
lines opened up their their win total
like I factored in juice on these which
is obviously very important because that
affects like the odds of winning you
have to calculate that like six and six
and a half if it's plus 110 to the over
versus minus 150 - you ever like a lot
of people will just say all their win
total six and a half well it's totally
different in the new to the window it's
a minus 145 you're like what am I doing
here right so they're their win total I
think when it first opened versus where
it is now has moved towards the north
when i factor in the juice by over a
half a win Wow which is the most of any
team in the league right now I'm spot on
the day cool I mean anyone else that it
sticks out I don't want to give away
your bets
no we I mean like we said we haven't
tailor their teams like the Patriots
have lived at 11:12 for like the last
decade
I always feel confident betting I think
I've seen it more than 11 over 20 this
year I looked yeah it's 11 over 20 at
canter
it's 11 - 105 at at Caesars AE to the
over it's 11 - 150 at LVH so at Westgate
so that's that's where exactly what
we're talking about having different
outs you can get 11 - 105 at Caesars but
if you go to West Westgate or you're
paying 11 - 150 right you have you
what's the would you ever pay juice like
that well sure yeah yeah I'd rather
especially on key numbers sure yeah I'd
rather take three in a football game you
know -
three and then minus 3 and 1/2 minus
1/10 I rattle they minus 3 minus 20 I go
out on this I want you to explain key
numbers to people because I don't think
people value a six and a half versus a
seven here two and a half versus a three
sure well years ago it really mattered
before they moved the extra point back
ten ten yards because the three was the
number that came out the most in the NFL
at one time lines that were lined out
the games that were line three up to 15
percent of those games for given any
given season landed on three so
therefore it's very important to buy on
or off of three in the NFL the casinos
all know this now and maybe do the shows
like this or I was pretty quiet about it
at first and other shows had a LAN now
all every single sports book when I
first came to Vegas in the 90s you can
literally buy off of three for ten extra
cents now most of the sports book one of
them let you move off the three they
know it's that valuable and you're
saying like pay money to move right from
three words to it if you're gonna lay
three points on a game you rather lay
two and a half points and lay 120 then
lathe - three - a dollar ten right so
therefore they don't even let you move
it no more so yeah some of them do but
they charge you a premium they're gonna
charge you 30 or 40 cents extra Wow just
like I'm the teasers this past year the
teachers were out of control the prices
they're not even worth betting anymore
you used to just you know like to bet
these key numbers because most of the
games like I said land the three or
seven yeah the visible 3 7 10 4 is the
fourth key number yeah why is for the
kingdom for 10 20 for 20 solo show and
you know games we score touchdown seven
the other score team scores three four
so it could be divisible also higher and
higher like that
so NFL teasers with these home teams
that were favored by eight or nine
points you can tease down through the
key numbers of seven and three - under
three - like minus 2 or minus two and a
half right well now these sports books
know what people are doing that
especially with the home teams and
they're saying hey basically the home
team just has to win the game and
they're saying you know for now on we're
we're not gonna charge 130 on these
teasers no more now they're 140 150 some
of the sports books are charging 150
dollars for 100 on a seven-point Caesar
even with those through those key
numbers mathematically it's not in your
favor no more the sports books have even
this
eles there and and and you know you're
not getting that those points anymore
but there's still some teasers I know
that that that I do that are definitely
mathematically vantage advantages and I
I do vet them and I bet a lot of money
on them and one was in action most
people didn't catch it but I bet a
three-team teaser in the NFL six point
teaser where you're moving all three
teams are actually taking a dollar
seventy or a Tyler 80 for every 100 some
of the sports workers have caught on to
that also and they've lowered it down to
like a dollar 40 but there's still a
couple of that have it plus 170 and it's
a good bet and listen I I can lose on
them for sure but I'll tell you what I
think I have an edge when I'm betting a
teaser certain numbers like that I think
your confidence speaks for itself
you guys on Twitter you are Bill crack
man yeah k ra ce que ma ma n and then
the app that you have is crack wind yes
sir I think it's very aesthetically
pleasing I was going through it last
night it looks really good and the the
rub there is that if you pay for the
service they get to bet with you bet 90%
of the stuff's free I write articles I
give you terms that I use crack ology
yeah photo quote yeah just some term to
end and there's a lot of articles there
on bankroll management what you should
start with and and and just there's an
autobiography there where I started my
whole life you want to read about this
stuff's all free to you so the app has
some great information plus we even give
out free pics on the app and Warren
Sharpe you're on twitter at sharp
football and your website that's really
comprehensive a sharp football analysis
calm are you gonna be putting on another
book this year I am by the end of June
so it's hard already right harp hardcore
writing phase right now research writing
and and that's going to be up by the end
of June by the beginning of July and so
will you have to wait for things like
next week May 8th is right after the May
7th
like there's like a deadline there and I
expect a lot of free agents to get
signed like the Ezekiel answers the
world because it's not gonna count
against compensatory pick so will you
have to like factor that in or is that
like a rewrite no yeah genders and
sometimes it's it's a rewrite like
obviously I do capture in the book all
the key free agents that have been added
so I just have to go add that person in
there in other cases there may be the
need to like hey they
in a dress this position enough and it's
a weakness and then they get a pass
rusher and so you have to kind of like
modify that a little bit one of the
things I loved about your book and I've
talked about the last time you're on
before you came on is just your overall
analysis of play calling into the league
and I think you just you [ __ ] hit it
last year with you need to throw the
ball more to running backs and tight
ends on early downs and have early down
success have you already started
formulating what your big thesis
statement will be yeah I do not want to
hear it know that that I've been a lady
quarterly it comes well it's natural
because throughout the course of
watching football for the last year I've
had things that are on my mind that are
bothersome to me that teams are doing
one angle I always write that at the end
I always write that article like the big
article at the end I'm contemplating
although I haven't like verified that
I'll definitely do this contemplating
writing instead of last year what teams
should do contemplating writing what
team should stop doing what bothers me
the most about what teams currently are
doing so I may go that route I may I may
try something else but nice that's the
last kind of that's a lot that's my
ability to get out all my frustrations
all the hours that I'm pouring into the
book that you're going through so many
numbers of teams that some of those
numbers have to annoy you
yes tremendously tremendously why are
you running on first down now or why
you're running on second and ten I think
is upset you more than anything yeah I
mean different quarterbacks I mean like
the Seattle Seahawks with Russell Wilson
why are you trying to be such a running
run first offense yeah there's a lot of
different scenarios that bother the hell
out of me why are third downs are you
throwing it five yards down the field
you need to be throwing it 10 to 15
yards down the field and the NFL
listeners his tweets have more people in
Scouting departments executives your
cohort was you see was looking millions
of hits on some of his tweets you got
then you get 10 million on the one I
mean oh yeah 10 million hits are you
kidding me I mean did peep trust me
executives have seen him and he wrote
his book a few times like I think they
were listening to me because like
Sarkisian yeah the Falcons last year
yeah Falcons last year you're like I
just noticed I kept tweeting about
something and then halfway through the
year
they completely went in that direction
well the tea it's it's it's funny I
didn't think that that was the case but
then I get different teams reaching out
to me and and different people high up
in the organization so I'm at the
highest spots are saying yeah I've been
I've been reading your stuff for years
and I don't know if they're highest
spots but I I don't know if they're kind
of you know just being nice to me or if
they really are but you know sometimes I
just say things and stuff I've really
enjoyed this I have one last story thing
that I'm gonna ask about being an East
Coast guy did you have any experiences
with wagering on the East Coast back
with you know hey I'm going to break
your leg and bookies and luckily enough
no I mean they they just threw me out
years ago when I used to bet with local
guys you know five years ago and they
just threw you out a lot of guys would
actually say to me man listen I take on
everyone but you really you're the real
deal now they just throw you out and you
just hope to get paid I just wrote an
article about this week it's funny
you're saying it this week's article in
gaming today was just about this how
years ago it was so easy to get you know
you gotta get thrown out you get paid
now article oh you did see and now in
2019 you it's a different story now I
have to worry about the sports bullet
pain now how I play with brick and
mortar how wild is it to be in this
world now where it's it's encouraged
that all of these major networks want to
make gambling content like I feel like
you guys went from the shadows to the
light and I mean can you even like
understand it like is it still shocking
at all yeah I guess I guess it is but
you know I have to tell you IIIi badger
shadows more no I noticed I wouldn't be
here yeah so I'll talk about it but I
try to educate people to most important
to me that if anything else I do I don't
want these kids in all these gaming
jurisdictions that just legalized sports
betting to think hey man I used to watch
Kobe I watch LeBron now I could beat
that all these kids that grew up on ESPN
say and I could go to the casino and win
don't worry absolutely not it's not
gonna happen you're gonna bet with your
heart you're gonna bet with emotion
you're gonna do all these things I
preach about not doing so this is not
for this
under 35 crowd as easy as you think it
is guys but but I won't reciate you say
them yeah I will say the the cool part
about this is the one of the reasons why
it is kind of easy is that there you
don't we don't have to act any
differently than what we normally are
like he's acting like he normally acts
and he's betting what he normally bets
and it's so it's easy it's it's natural
to talk about it right on shows like
this or because they will just weren't
listening
yeah people people didn't care as much
now people are going to care but you
know it's it's a lot easier to see and
appreciate when somebody's being genuine
yeah of course I'll just havin Pat my
own back we had our draft guys in
because I think things like the draft
are really nice to bet because it's not
the bounce of a ball it's information
and people have information and I went
back and I listened to our bets I think
we went like six of eight which I feel
pretty good like we're on one level over
on Clemson over on Alabama players
drafted first wide receiver drafted they
knew what they were doing
Johnny Rodgers Matt Miller absolutely
pretty much that stuff the crack warren
sharp cracking the sharks sharp crack
coming to a store near check it out
crack winds sharp full ball analysis you
guys are awesome appreciate you
appreciate you homies 33 percent you all
as a [ __ ] college you later